ok alles gleich begrüße alle zuschauer
der zu hause an den monitor und die
kandidaten ihr im seminar wir machen
heute märz-sitzung bei mir im büro also
schon temperaturen versteht ist dass er
nicht so viele anreden sind wir machen
die sitzung vielleicht auch ein bisschen
kürzer aber wir sollten schon noch die
abschlusssitzung ein bisschen bestreiten
weil heute geht es ein ganz brisantes
thema heute geht es über das thema
politik der digitalität das ist ein
spannendes thema wir wollen nicht nur
politik der digitalität werden sondern
wir wollen auch noch ein bisschen auf
die ethischen problematik eingehen
die wir auch schon der letzten sitzung
kurz angesprochen haben
wir hatten dort gesehen es gibt eine
charta und wir wohnen sie nochmal
anschauen weil ich nicht untätig
geblieben bin weil ich nämlich da auch
ein bisschen mit kommentiert habe bei
diesen ganzen texten also letzte sitzung
niedriger die vitalität der knüpfen
heute an
leitfragen waren der sitzung wie ein
bild der digitalisierung ethische
problem jetzt sind diese probleme von
anderer art als analoge ethischen
probleme wie lässt sich eine ethik der
digitalität entwickeln
wie finden es diese tätige die vitalität
digitale tätig vom normalen kritiken und
technik tätigen verschiedensten
techniken darunter fällt auch roboter
nötig würde ich auch als technik ansehen
spannend wird es dann wenn es um ethik
der künstlichen intelligenz geht ein
künstliches liegen sicherlich in form
von technik ist die aber sehr neu ist
und hier stellen sich den fragen nach
goma entscheidung
inwiefern sind künstliche intelligenzen
als akteure anzusehen das ist mit
problematik und jetzt hatte ich den
letzten sitzung an der teilnehmerinnen
und teilnehmer hingewiesen auf diese
charta der digitalen grundrechte der
europäischen union bis zum versuch ist
ein bisschen zu systematisieren
die digital digitale karte hat lewis die
adresse und ich möchte auch noch ein
bisschen eigentlich weil das kann ich
jetzt immer vielleicht ein bisschen zu
kurz
der hintergrund ist der dass 2016
da so ein vorschlag digitalen
grundrechte eingebracht wurde und seit
dezember hat das publikum die
möglichkeit diese digitalen grundrechte
artikel zu diskutieren und wir als
wieder so viele philosophen zeugen davon
gebrauch machen das habe ich auch
ich zeige ihnen einmal sogar kommentare
ich dazu eine post habe und dann ist
natürlich immer höflich sei ein
konstruktiver dialog wird gefordert das
habe ich auch versucht zu machen
wir können einfach mal so ein bisschen
durchgehend auch mal auch ein bisschen
springer als die würde des menschen ist
da und digitalen zeitalter unantastbar
sie muss ziel und zweck aller
technischen entwicklung seien und der
clans deren einsatz
was damit dem stimme ich natürlich zu
womit ich ein bisschen probleme hat ist
das hier immer nur von technische
entwicklung die rede ist ich glaube
nämlich dass hier nur auf die
digitalisierung geschaut wird und das
phänomen der digitalität im blick wird
digitalität ist wie wir gesehen und
diese semester mehr essen die technik
sondern die vitalität und fast neuer
lebens halten soll ich sonst machen es
vielleicht sie sagen sie kann es auch
noch den letzten platz waren haben keine
titel vertreiben ist nur wenige tage und
kann ja also das hier ist auch der
monitor zu sehen
sie können vielleicht dahin und sehen
sie nicht als nachteil
also ich dachte also das ist für mich
jetzt ein bisschen zu kurz gefasst hier
zu sagen nur technisch entwickeln die
vitalität ist eine kulturelle wie können
neue form des zusammenlebens und durch
neue technische entwicklung die im
winter friert also ich glaube hier wird
immer nicht bei diesen ganzen artikeln
gesehen dass wir sie mit einem neuen
realität zu tun haben mit einer
virtuellen realität
das ganze scheint mir noch sehr vom
gesichtspunkt der traditionelle teams
entwickelte sein
natürlich ist es klar dass die würde
auch im digitalen zeitalter unantastbar
ist wird es die frage wie kann sie denn
angetastet werden
und wie verhindern wir dass in der viele
digitalität angetastet
haben sie denn also ich kann ja nicht so
ganz genau folgen insofern als das ja
zum beispiel im grundgesetz wo ja auch
so ein paragraph steht ja auch nicht auf
die spezifika eingegangen wird sondern
das wird ja erst mal allgemein
dargestellt und darum kann ich eben
schon folgen hier also anders als gegen
das man sagt ja man man nimmt erstmal
nur beziehung auf den begriff
des menschen und anderen vielleicht
später oder in den anderen zusammenhang
das nochmal ausdiskutieren oder die
interferenzen da bei karl d
ja mit sicherheit also das sicherlich
unstrittig mir schon ist eben nur so zu
sein dass die einst zu einzelnen
anwendung der analogen ethik auf die
digitale mit den stattfindet das ist
sicherlich richtig aber ich finde man
muss immer wenn man seine würde fordert
vor gewissen erfahrungen diese würde
formulieren im grundgesetz fans die ihre
erfahrung des ersten weltkriegs damit
eingeflossen sind es verhindert und das
grundgesetz und ich frage mich familie
im hintergrund jetzt eine würde digitale
gefordert ich glaube dass das keine
basis bilde sich also ich glaube dass
das einfach sollten luft gegriffen ist
in analogie zu erobern würde
und wir brauchen erst die phänomene vor
deren hintergrund wir die situation und
notwendigkeit gesetzt sind alle die
einen würden digitalen zeitalter zu
fordern
sonst hängt das alles für mich ein
bisschen hilft natürlich kann man sagen
sie gegenüber allen die würde zu
schützen dann auch im digitalen bereich
aber der minister fragen warum reden wir
daher explizit im digitalen zeitalter
welche herausforderungen ergeben sich
diese herausforderung ist nicht in die
formulierung des artikels eingehen
müssen explizit und aber genauso wie man
erst mal bock erfahren bei erfahrungen
sammeln muss mit dem einfluss der
digitalität oder
errungenschaften der digitalität und die
die neuen lebensumstände die damit
einhergehen um sagen wir mal das
differenzierter auszuformulieren man
sieht das ja schon an diesen
problematiken wenn die jungen sich über
autonomes fahren und erhalten auch da
ist hat man das gefühl da ja da weiß
keiner so richtig wo man solle sich denn
jetzt orientieren
da sagen wir mal pipelines aufzustellen
um sich dem zu nehmen wir also wirklich
richtig ich glaube eben orientieren
müssen sie sich an dem philosophen und
philosophen die uns wie sie sind und
zwar an einer un homme qui der
digitalität und auch der ereignisse
damit will ich folgendes sagen wir
hatten in der vorletzten sitzung gemacht
und rechts anderen linken noch mal die
frage nach der theologie der digitalität
aufgerufen hier war das stichwort
virtuelle realität virtuelle realität
wird immer noch viel zu häufig mit dick
mit simulationen gleichgesetzt
wenn ich mir so eine 3d brille aufsetzen
dann hat das immer inbegriffen und
logisch nichts mit virtueller realität
zu tun ist eine sehr gute simulation und
damit zusammenhängt die frage nach der
ontologie von virtuellen ereignissen
oder handelt kommt erst ein endspiel um
es mit handlungen und aktionen zu tun
haben die zurechnung belassen das heißt
bevor wir so eine ethik die
digitalisierung oder wir fordern müssen
sie uns
erst darüber klar werden welche unter
logisches das virtuelle aktionen
handlungen und auch virtuelle akteure
haben
der begriff je person wurde kürzlich
eingeführt damit sind zb auf ordnung
scheint künstlers ergänzt gefallen aber
ich denke auch wir selbst als
nutzerinnen und nutzer des internets wer
durch mehr zum raum zeitlich vor ort
waren personen
sie werden zu erpressen dina ganz
anderen raum zeit und deren handlungen
aber andere und energie haben aber es
ist zum beispiel handlungen der
physikalischen welt zum beispiel an sich
selbst einmal gesagt glaube ich dass
physische gewalt in der es werde
digitalität fast keine rolle mehr spielt
wir können dann virtuell nur sehr
schlecht physische gewalt anwandte
hinzufügen wie ich es jetzt hier könnte
das mit mir könnten
dafür steht andre formen der kränkung
oder psychischer gewalt im zentrum
psychoterror cybermobbing unser land zu
fahren aber die anthologie der
ereignisse die anthologie die handlungen
die scheint sich hier statt zu inneren
dementsprechend mussten frage ob es
nicht auch eine modifizierte form von
angewandte von politik ein spezifisches
verbieten
folgt jetzt haben wir hier noch einen
weiteren punkt nämlich freiheit
jeder hat das recht auf freie
information kommunikation
dieses recht ist konstitutiv für die
freie gesellschaft ist beinhaltet das
recht auf nichtwissen
da hatten wir uns schon im letzten satz
ein bisschen aufgehängt wie viel haben
wir ein recht auf nicht wissen
ich darf von händlern an die sitzungen
bei dem thema informationen beschäftigt
haben ich mache das wieder auch oben
rechts und linken
hier ist natürlich ganz zentral und
cherno flori dieses begriff der info
sphäre den fonds fähre gibt es nicht
erst seit der erfindung der computer
sondern im ausschaltzeiten welt
gutenberg galaxis von der felix stalder
spricht auch diese teile in frustrierend
aber die information wäre viel besser
verfügbar
im zeitalter der digitalität weil sie
nicht mehr auf zeitlich diese grenzen
logik folgen des ungetrübten bühne stand
folgen
sie lassen sich grenze geld einfach
vervielfältigen sie lassen sich durch
alle möglichen von zugangs haben wir
jetzt das tablet hier smartphone wird
immer sogar mit google suchen und so
weiter schließen
und jetzt stellt sich dann die frage
wenn wir es nicht so viel informations
planen die uns ja auch sehr viel wissen
inwiefern haben wir dann das recht uns
auch aus dieser informationen
zurückzuziehen so jedenfalls
interpretiert here diesen satz das recht
auf nicht ist kann den durchaus folgen
weil sie können wir endlich sicher sein
dass das wissen was wir haben auch
wirklich richtig erzählt sie
infos wäre sich erarbeiten dass das
richtig wie auch immer in der begriff
jetzt ne gedeutet wird
und damit könnte er könnte keiner darauf
festgenagelt werden dass er etwas wissen
muss die frage ist halt gibt es nicht
richtiges wissen oder ist wenn man etwas
reißt es dann richtig insofern ist
bewusst als gibt es falsches wissen dass
die frage wie wir wissen definiert wird
das systemische frage also wenn man
wisse nämlich fast dann wäre wissen
immer wahre gerechtfertigt gemeinde und
dann hätte man probleme damit so zu
argumentieren dass man etwas nicht
wissen so etwas nicht wissen darf wie
ihr alle nach der wahl strebsame unser
wissen familien zahlen bei wenn wir
jetzt nicht vergeben
dann könnte man uns vorwerfen dass sie
zwar hätte es wissen können haben uns
aber nicht drin
und wenn wir dann ein problem haben es
ist uns selbst zuzurechnen
vom moralischen standpunkt
möglicherweise aber das wäre der einzige
stangen standen punkten wobei es nicht
schwer nachzuweisen ist es eine genau
die zeit in der fräse falsche mann also
falsche informationen vorher weil die
ideen kontext gibt es dann natürlich
auch wichtige informationen
ja da haben sie bestätigt also glaube
dass hier eine ganz große problematik
bekommt auch die waren informationen
können
sie unterscheiden und die szenische wir
uns orientieren können
als er ist natürlich der begriff des
nichtwissens nicht geklärt das ist also
das ist hier hier muss noch einiges
geklärt wer das hat natürlich auch nur
vorläufig aber da habe ich nicht so ein
bisschen aufgehalten hier das recht auf
nichtwissen haben vielleicht ein
bisschen meine probleme natürlich kann
man das hätten andere potsdam auch sagen
wir wollen wir sollten das recht auf
eine analoge welt geladen und ist damit
auch gemeinden die frage die damit sagen
dass die müssen wir gibt es die pflicht
auf dieses digitalen zug mitzufahren
oder sollten wir noch analoge räume
si/ds siegen unter offen halten zum
beispiel dass man sich auch noch
schriftlich anmelden kann in der zukunft
behauptet werden anmelde und
kommunikationsverfahren rein digital
geführt und man wird sogar gar kein
recht mehr draufhaben auf eine andere
weise zu kommunizieren oder zb sich
anzumelden oder einzuschreiben
viele online viele einschreibungen
versteht und gelaufen nur noch einmal
wenn ich dadurch das online formular
auszufüllen habe ich keine chancen
nichts immatrikulieren und ich glaube
dass nur der frage der zeit ist bis das
analoge residenz schicke bereich immer
mehr reduziert wird immer mehr eingeengt
wird bis es gar kein licht mit
aufgegeben die frage ist ja gut ist es
ist eigentlich genau das problem also
ich denke da grad an ist es pflicht
lesen und schreiben zu können
deutschland schon am schulkiosk sie
können sie können sich aber trotzdem
verweigern dann wird er aber glaube ich
die produkte
die exekutive eine beschreiten
das leben hier diese schriftlich gibt
auch eltern die ihre kinder nicht in die
schule schicken die werden gesetzlich
blanken ja also dass die die
schulpflicht schon aber das irdische
können ja sein dass der eine oder andere
im lernen verbreitet
die frage ist dann kann der belangt
werden dafür weshalb ich lesen und nicht
schreiben kann dass es vielleicht nicht
will wer es nicht kann es gibt der
legastheniker der das militär wies
könnte und ich will und sich verweigert
das eine spannende frage also mit der
schriftlichkeit zusammen haben sie
natürlich recht man könnte prinzipiell
sicher einschulen lassen an schulen und
der widersetzt sich den fragen und wie
fern besteht dann hier das recht diesen
personen zu zwingen passiert oder ist
nicht lernen und lesen und schreiben
eine freie entscheidung und spannende
frage wann es gibt sicherlich die eine
oder andere argumente dafür die argument
dafür dass es eine pflicht ist sind die
dass man sich sonst aus dem sozialen
rauf abschiede und dass es im grunde um
den bürger pflicht ist dem die
grundstruktur zu teilen das ist sprach
in lesen schreiben und partizipation
dass das st die bedingung der
möglichkeit wahr
da bin ich zu wenige juristen die
schulpflicht werden jetzt wahrscheinlich
einfach so weitergehen
also ist kein fahrfehler die
verschreibungen tatsächlich
hier finden also trotzdem bearbeitung
sie arbeiten können mehr und erfüllen
damit sozusagen wichtig dass man keine
kann sie zwingendes lesen und schreiben
zu werden solange sie und geben
wertvolle teil der gesellschaft sind auf
jeden fall wichtig da musste natürlich
über die freiheit auch tun was ihr im
selben maße ist natürlich dass er die
teilhabe an an dem sozialen leben
eingeschränkt genauso dies
möglicherweise dann in zukunft
eingeschränkt ist wenn man sagen wir mal
auf dem anderen drogen gemacht und da
ist die kranke digitalen verweigert die
frage ob es eine möglichkeit gibt und
inwieweit die freiheit darauf besteht
sich dir zu ziehen
ob man da was einklagen kann man zum
beispiel einkehren könnte sich auch noch
eine lohnkosten artikulieren universität
das würde mich interessieren und ich das
einschlagen kann weil ich meine es wäre
eine grundfreiheit troffen gepaart
situation wenn sie die fragen der
partizipation also ich weiß nur dass
mittlerweile
kennen sie ja gar keine fahrkarten mehr
kaufen nächstens nicht auf nebenstrecken
dass sie keine chance haben zu sagen da
ich konnte den zweiten auch noch nicht
richtig gemacht gemeint was ist dieses
sekunden ist es ist ja auch wert ist es
fast genau dabei und es wird nicht
anerkannt nun genau die hat also hätte
könnte auf gar keine basis mehr dagegen
klar gemacht dass er gleich halten
können bisher überspringen jeder mensch
hat das recht auf eine gleichberechtigte
teilhabe in der digitalen sphäre was
heißt überhaupt digitale sphäre wird gar
nicht definiert ist damit infos wäre
gemeint die digitale sphäre ist damit
die kultur der digitalität gemeint er
ist damit das internet gewalt also wir
alle mal so kommt wenn sie kommentieren
weil ihr kommentar die ganze mittel
verhindern ein bisschen die luft
die müssen alle noch genau definiert
werden das natürlich eine aufgabe von
uns philosoph findet und wir suchen
zuerst zu klären und da ist wenn man
würde dafür orientieren und solchen
katalog aufzustellen aufstellen so
basilika tage die itan richten müssen
wir jetzt die ganze ontologie der
digitalität verstanden haben
man hätte so ein grundgesetz
entwickeln können wie aufstellen können
wenn man es hunderte von jahren schon
davor sich gedanken um die ontologie von
hand gemacht hätte von ein eigenes und
so weiter das ist alles für ausgelegt
und das ist hier auch nötig denn sonst
sehen wir das alles nur analog zu allen
leuten und das ist gefährlich bei einer
bestimmten entwicklung nicht gerecht
werden kann müssen gewisse modifikation
anbringen sonst sehen wir dinge die dann
ganz böse enden können wir bestimmt aber
das ist zu mir waren die ich hier so ein
bisschen ansprechen möchte aber darüber
kann natürlich auch diskutieren innere
sicherheit
hier ist natürlich gerade das problem
der massenüberwachung ist ein problem
daniel waffensysteme dürfen nicht voll
automatisiert eingesetzt werden also
drohnen zu unterstellen
drohnen haben zb gesichtserkennung haben
könnte man damit ohne bauen
gesichtserkennung hat und wer garantiert
uns dass das richtig gesicht erkennt
vielleicht hat sich ja mal jemand ein
bisschen die maske aufgesetzt oder so
wie einen terroristen erleben möchte der
schwierigen vor allem auch wer hat die
verantwortung voll automatisierte
waffensysteme der drohnen leiter der
ingenieur der programmierer
meinungsfreiheit ganz wichtiger punkt da
jeder hat das recht der digitalen welt
sein in meinem freizupressen
eine 10 zur führung statt bedarf an
dieses netz gesetzt erinnert es kürzlich
entlassen wurde von heiko maas für nicht
sicher dass sich uns in meinem
einschränkt digitale hetze modelle sowie
aktivitäten die eigenen sünden ruf oder
unversehrtheit an der person ernsthaft
zu gefährden sind zu verhindern
das heißt verhindern was heißt gitarre
herzen und liefern konfiguriert die
einschränkung dass verbote digitalen
herzen altonas gramm meinungsfreiheit
und fans natürlich einen straftatbestand
unter umständen also es gibt ja der
volksverhetzungsparagraf der ist klar
definiert
aber wann es etwas hetze wenn sie uns
nicht direkt darunter fällt also hier
riesen thema meinungsfreiheit digitale
meinung gerade auch deswegen weil
twitter wie wir alle wissen durch die
zeichen beschränkung dazu direkt
animiert seine thesen zu kommentieren
und mehr auszubauen als zu begründen
damals option wenig platz um die thesen
zu bekommen hatte alcoa eröffnete
diskurs vorzustellen
dann haben wir dadurch sichergestellt
dass wir einfach das internet am leben
halten und das internet zensieren und
des realen menschen auf der welt an
internetanschluss bieten so ein wenig
strom war und wasser und wärme bieten
und nahrung
das internet ist zu mehr grundlos ein
grundbedürfnis geworden und das will
jeder auch die notwendige
geschwindigkeit
das internet zugriffs geben die
datengeschwindigkeit darf und ausländer
also nicht hier mit moderner 7 kilobyte
pro sekunde
dass man vielleicht man könnte sich
glücklich überlegt ob man das genauer
spezifiziert auch im rechten wie schnell
die verbindungs sein muss dann überlegen
sie man hat gravierende nachteile wenn
man kein langsames internet hat das ist
genauso wie wenn sie mit strom mit einer
bestimmten frequenz amt nur um
schwachstrom ahnung die starkstrom
das ist alles noch spezifiziert werden
dann darf natürlich keine seite gesperrt
werden müssen auf alle zeit zu
vertreiben dürfen und ich hatte sofort
das ist der übergang vom intranet zum
internet also das internet hatten sich
die tendenz sich zu entgrenzten und es
ist in meinen augen mit grund
demokratische zu alles mit allem in
verbindung setzt keine riesige oder zu
schaffen keine rückzugsräume und alles
muss und alle fans wirken und jeder hat
das recht sich von jedem knoten konnte
das ganze netz 1 zu gelangen
die kein privilegierten zugang zu das
ist ein grund demokratisches ein
globales denken und gewalt vor
die wir glaube ich am leben halten
müssen ich glaube dass die struktur des
internets maßgeblich auf eine dicke
tante
wir können diese liegt an der struktur
des internets gewissermaßen ablesen
aber ich glaube dass ich viele ethische
fragen direkt an der bewertung oder
anders des internets gestalten und nicht
so sehr der frage einer künstlichen
glaube das internet ist das zentrum
politische macht die meisten virtuell
aktivitäten die ethisch problematisch
sind finde - start werden oder sehen sie
das anders
also die meisten kann ich sagen dass ich
zu wenig im überblick aber es finden
natürlich mit einer menge etwa neue
länder statt
also wenn man zum beispiel diesen
ominösen kräfte staaten mehr dann ist so
sehr
einerseits sommer wird es als als die
insel gepriesen wo man anonym
arbeiten kann auf der anderen seite
natürlich dann gleich ausgenutzt die
anonymität und es werden dass straftaten
oder anfangen durch initiiert oder ist
dieser nun schwieriger wie genau es
damit widerspricht eigentlich dem
prinzip des internets beißenden intranet
ist das abschotten zu besiedeln und man
kann mit vpn man kann auch mit kleinen
zu hause im kleinsten ins internet geht
da wird ein eigener ip verschlüsselt er
hält es keine vorstrafen und die frage
ist im liefern muss ein nutzer eine
nutzerin die sich ins internet begibt
auch rückverfolgbar sein
oder geht der datenschutz so weit dass
man seine spuren verwischen kann und
wenn das der fall ist dass wir alle
unseren vergiften können zum beispiel
können
dann bekommt ihr neues geblieben nämlich
dasjenige das unsere handlungen die wir
beginnen im internet nicht mehr in den
effizient nutzen und das ist glaube ich
in dimension des intensiven zu lösen ich
glaube das anders darauf hinausläuft
dass wir viel weniger identifizierbar
sein werden
das sind ganz neue dimensionen weil wir
in der physikalischen welt
alle reden denn effizient die
hinterlassenen physikalisch und
verfolgten und weiß nicht
und es wäre möglich dass eine sphäre
existiert in dem wir keine spuren
hinterlassen aber dennoch aktiv werden
und stellen sich fragen nach
urheberschaft verantwortung ist als in
deutschland
es waren auch kollektiv verwaltungen
oder anonyme oder auch kollektive auto
schafft und denken sie an expedia sie
wissen gar nicht am ende werden es
artikel geschrieben hat
das ist ein problem weswegen ich eben
abgeraten
wikipedia als wissenschaftliche quelle
zu besetzen aber es könnte sein dass in
der digitalisierung als kulturell
gesehen ein ganz neue begriffe
autorenschaft entsteht kollektive
verbünde die insgesamt sind und dennoch
etwas schaffen das ist eine ganz neue
dimension von autorschaft auch so was
wie freier zugang access open access als
neuen modelle der vermarktung neue
systeme des viertels gleich zu bekommen
der irrt draufgehen meinungsfreiheit
endlichkeit jedoch leben mit dieser
meinungsbildung vorfallen könnte mich
bringt algorithmen ja finde ich ganz
bezahlt jeder hat das recht nicht
objekten automatisierten entscheidung
von erheblicher bedeutung für die
edition zu sein also die fahnenoffiziere
ich hatte ja der begriff der inter
objektivität in spiel gebracht für die
mentalität
ich glaube dass sie aus der
effektivierung gar nicht herauskommen
können
ich glaube aber dass im bereich der
digitalität objektivierung keine
problematische sache ist und zwar
deswegen weil der internet immer darauf
ausgerichtet
sind zu teilen das internet ist nicht
nur ein verbindungsnetz sind es noch ein
teil projektion das ist ein system des
teilens und das bedeutet dass wir unsere
subjektivität nach außen kehren und im
grunde genommen die differenz von
subjektiven objektivität im internet
auflegen
das ist glaube ich eine ganz
interessante struktur und hier greift in
meinen augen dieser vorwurf der
vergeblich um eine person nicht mehr
sondern das internet und die digitale
welt eben gerade die tendenz zu
objektivieren
aber das heißt objektiviert oder wird
zugleich auch subjektiv als solche nicht
nur die personen als ein gegenstand
verhandeln sondern die virtualität
virtuelle realität kann gewissermaßen
nur durch vor objektivierung entstehen
also nicht unbedingt problematisch sein
muss künstliche intelligenz ethischen
normativ entscheidungen können nur von
menschen getroffen werden wo hier sehen
sie das es gibt die teure entwicklung
der künstler für die ganze darf auch das
buch von philipp später erweisen
diese trends digitalisierung april steht
das beschreibt schon erste küste geld
gibt
mit normativen und einen film sehen sie
das
problematisch glaube ich habe nur das
davon gelesen das glaube ich an
amerikanischen unis dass das da
aufnahmeverfahren mit mit algorithmen
teilweise gesperrt werden
also teilweise und ich glaube schon dass
das problematisch ist als wenn man zb
nach dem grund gefragt
dann würde man sich vielleicht auch
verhörten sie sagen dass man sich wenn
man von künstlicher intelligenz bewertet
wird
dass er seine frau objektiviert wird
oder zum gegenstand die qualität wird
unseren bloßen untersuchungsobjekt wird
weil die künstliche intelligenz der
abschied von unserer individualität und
uns nur quantität cannstatt ivm ist also
klassifiziert worden
nach diesem gegenstand der sie glauben
menschen können uns auch qualitativ die
wertschätzen besuchen will sich zu
orientieren
die frage ist immer ob wenn über
menschen entschieden wird ob das immer
objektivierbar sein muss
was nicht welche ihnen geld die von dem
wesen des menschen auch absehen kann
sich hier also das ist wirklich eine
wichtige frage die frage ist überhaupt
diese dieser punkt eins zu verliert ja
das heißt es können
das heißt es können entscheidungen
können nur von menschen betroffen
dann heißt es im sinne des vermögens als
er ist nur menschen vermögen dies zu tun
haben die fähigkeit zu oder er sie so zu
verstehen nur menschen dürfen
rechtlich ist so lese ich sehe mich
nicht nur menschen dürfte das tun und
maschinen dürften es nicht wird es nun
klarheit man das sehen wir als wir
suchen hier chris können es unklar
gute wetter ist dann immer noch macht
das problem dürfen für solche
entscheidungen
algorithmen zur hilfe bezogen werden und
dann bis zu welchem grad es ist ja nicht
immer so es entweder macht man das eine
oder das andere
meistens wird einmal so eine mischform
gehen und dann kommt das problem bis zu
welchem grad darf davon dem algorithmus
da folgen und und wann muss der mensch
also in denen kontext entscheiden
also ich glaube dass das sehr sehr
schlimm aber ich muss nicht irgendwie ja
die frage ist eben auch wenn ich die
können
[Musik]
selbst lernende marschieren im absatz 3
zucker wird wird auch wirklich handeln
die lauteste für die handlungen selbst
werden in der maschine die daraus
resultierende folgen mussten meine
natürliche oder juristische person
verantwortlich sei
hier wird vorausgesetzt das
selbstlernende maschinen damit zb
künstliche neuronale netzwerke gemeint
dass die hand nehmen können der mittels
der handlung ist völlig unter bestimmten
ja könnte es denn so was gegen das
natürliche oder juristische person war
nicht involviert ist in so was
es könnte zum beispiel sei das ein
künstliches neuronales netz letztlich
für selbständige das durchlaufen und
neue farben ursprünglich gar nicht
schauen sie wenn sie neuronales netz auf
den daten des angst dann können sie
extreme schäden aufgrund der riesen
retten und knotenpunkte diesen die
blogger gehört sie könnte es praktisch
gar nicht richtig bis hämisch berechnen
was rauskommt sie können es theoretisch
waren aber es ist so komplex unendlich
schwer politischen
aber sie können gar nicht voraus und
darauf das ganze hinaus also den wenigen
in das system
und so könnte es dann zuwendungen kommen
die sich abkapseln gewissermaßen und so
eine neue erkenntnis ziel führen was ihr
anfang gar nicht intendiert also mir
verselbstständigung und die relative
selbst und über die entscheidung oder
oder der hand man wird ja immer im sinne
ihrer und einer natürlichen oder
juristischen oder oder organe oder
staatlichen organisationen bericht
geführt natürlich kann sich das
personell im jahr
aber da steckt ja auch eine gewisse
intention dahinter sohns würde man das
ja gar nicht darauf ansetzen und dann
ging's richtig ja es ist ist diese
zuordnung eigentlich ja perioden gegeben
ja also sie haben recht das grundziel
die grundausrichtung und will zweck der
muss von außen gegeben werden eines
hatten werde ich mich im rechten video
rein dafür mehrere podcast dann wird
darüber diskutiert inwiefern künste die
ganze handeln kann
streng genommen nicht weil den künstlern
sie geht es immer einen zweck vorgegeben
bekommen es zb text erkennen bilder
können
von selbstauslösungen systemisch einem
zweck setzen
aber gegen die weiteren verlauf könnte
es zum mega zweck bekommen oder zu
abgeleiteten zwecken und also
hypothetischen oder bedingtem zwecken
die gar nicht vielleicht intendiert war
und ihr gesagt aber der absolute zweck
muss gesetzt deswegen sind auch künstler
intelligenz eigentlich nur quasi akteur
kann quasi handlungen vollziehen
und hier wird eben einfach energie von
handlungen gesprochen das ist in
modefragen müsste sagen für aktionen für
die aktionen hören oder die wirkung oder
die folgen haben nicht verhandlungen die
handlungs begriff muss expliziert werden
an dem heißt ein ziel sich zu setzen
heisst gründe zu geben
nationales netz setzt sich keine gründe
frage hatten
das interesse aller interesse dass ihm
vorgesetzt das hier muss noch vieles
hinterfragt werden transparenz kann man
denke ich über springen im fenster der
wohnung auch natürlich kann man sich
fragen wie weit schauen sie mal alexa
wer hat von alexa amazon alexa blauen
habe ich dann total nutzlos ok go wie
häufig waren sind es heute in münchen
heute 135 grad jetzt über 30 würde
ziemlich heiße ja das ist doch ganz
normal ihr smart home thema smart home
wir sind alle vernetzt alle unsere
zukunft zu besuch alle unsere geräte
stich von inter objektivität sondern
werden verletzt wird und prinzipiell
kann google alle daten auswerten
google weist alle sich startet für uns
und weißt was ich problematischer in
diesem kontext finde ist dass viele
menschen das
alexa zum beispiel und der festen
überzeugung sind dass alexa und damit
höher
nur hat es ansprechen und es seien mal
die leute hätten die nutzer explizit auf
solche problematiken auch in den wiesen
der gemacht es gab den fall dass
formation mitarbeiter das abgehört haben
es ist veröffentlicht wird kürzen
und es könnte durchaus sein dass auch
wenn alexander google mich aktiviert ist
eben alles aufgenommen wird und in die
datengrundlage eingespeist wird und
leben weiter selbst zu werden und dann
wird vielleicht daten konnte eigentlich
interpretiert der ausgewählten an das
ist zumindest da sind könnte ausgewählt
werden und könnte ein neuronales ganz
darauf ab richten wenn eine kontonummer
rauszubringen die da jemand mal genannt
hat oder geburtsdatum oder sonstige
konsumwünsche und an diesen person daran
werbe katalog ohne wertung in der spam
mails zu schicken sagte worüber du
redest mit einem paten am abend erst
nicht sagte wer du bist oder noch
einfacher
sag mir was dich interessiert nach was
für mich an wechselgeld gefragt und ich
sag dir was du bist
und auch nicht mehr das was 96 nach das
wie man das sagt also die ganzen anderen
parameter die bei der anfrage der
stimmen eine rolle spielen können das
sind so metadaten die auch geld genutzt
werden kann
das heißt man muss zum beispiel auch mal
überhaupt erstmal was es überhaupt mit
datum das ist eine information habe ich
eben von informationen gibt's
datenschutz daten zu trainieren jeder
hat das recht auf den schutz seiner
daten und die achtung seiner privaten ja
ja also hier erstmal muss man definieren
was zu braucht und datum was ist das
heißt schutz
personenbezogene daten wird nur noch
treue glaube unter festgelegte ziele
erhoben verarbeitet werden ganz spannend
ich meine was mich jetzt ein bisschen
ärgert das gab es neue gesetz müssen die
alle homepages monden diese lästig
balken wo man alles ab angeblich ist ja
ok cookies entscheiden also es ist für
mich immer als nutzer ziemlich lästig
aber gut nicht klicken einfach weg
[Musik]
fast abgebaut und im rucksack der
deutsche meister bestimmte taste
wunderbar jetzt zur thematik ist bei
jeder muss raus geht aus dem raum also
dass endlich soll es sogar ist soll
sogar die geht ja auch alles ins
getroffen
ja aber von ihnen gesteuert ja ich will
dass das problem ist ja noch mal es gibt
männer oder viele menschen die die sind
der meinung wenn sie in ihrem pferd
sind dringt nichts nach draußen wenn sie
alex atom prozessor ab was ist daraus
nicht mein ding und es ist es ist die
gefahr an dass das die menschen
vielleicht die die die auswirkungen gar
nicht denken können abschätzen können
und warum und warum und zwar deswegen
weil sie neues paradies wie sie richtig
sagen man denkt wenn ich in meinen vier
wänden sind trinkt nichts nach außen
viele denken nach außen tritt nur was
ich sage schreibe einen anderen direkt
dabei gibt es jetzt so viele
möglichkeiten zu registrieren die geräte
bieten teile werden immer kleiner
funkmodule wlan modul sind minimal
halten wir doch vor 20 jahren oder so
man denn seine wähler haben kraut pci
karten slot reinstecken mussten also
einen riesenanteil tauchte mittlerweile
sind die denn so klein wie sieht man
geachtet
das heißt die dinge werden gerne und sie
die regierenden und solo geht unsere
der kommunikation kommunikation immer
noch verstanden als problem um zu und
übermittlung der region oder schriftlich
schriftzeichen dass die
informationsübertragung auf ganz andere
wege verfolgen kann wird eben nicht
berücksichtigt
ja also jeder hat das recht auf
verschlüsselung der daten ich kann hier
nur noch sagen stichwort beim
medienkompetenz also das ist auch der
gute der meere in einem punkt betrifft
ist die rede von rechnung ist es ja auch
ein recht ich habe ich würde gerne auch
im pflichtenkatalog weise seite gesehen
beiseite stellen
die seite stellen damit man mal dem
markt lassen und selbst autos
das wird wird auf mich so als haben wir
hier alle nur echte und dürfen die hand
aufhalten und die anderen müssen sich
darum kümmert mich selbst kann gerade so
weiter machen ein bisschen ich glaube
wir können dann rechte einfordern können
wir auch bereits und pflichten einzigen
unsere hauptpflicht gilt in meinen augen
die rettung kommt es also eine
technische dinge informieren
vor allem ein kritisches urteilsvermögen
zu entwickeln wichtige von weniger
wichtige informationen zu schreiben und
zu wissen wie ich auf eine recht sichere
weise an eine information und das
blaulicht es ist das allergrößte problem
weil die innovationsgeschwindigkeit in
der beschleunigung
diaz ist hier dass sie im grunde
genommen gar nicht mehr nachkommen
ja immer auf dem laufenden zu sehr
wichtig dass ich kann mir nicht
vorstellen dass das dass irgendeiner was
ich vielleicht heute schon alles ist
alles abdecken kann ja thema wieder
recht auf nichtwissen
also sind wir thema als medienkompetenz
ja aber wenn wir das müssen müssen ja
erlebt alles wissen
spannende frage wie können wir nicht
weil vieles was wir wissen auch von
zufällen abhängig ob ich zur rechten
zeit welchen ort mit der echten personen
sprechen dem ich darauf hinweisen
spannendes thema ich möchte wurde auf
hinweisen mir kommen die pflichten zu
kurz wenn ich dann noch mal auf recht
auf verschlüsselung der daten
es ist ja schon ein problem zwischen
nation wenn ein fahrer hier vom
deutschen also hier in deutschland
unter den betrieben wird dann müssen die
daten sicher so in bei unternehmen die
oder bei daten die auf servern lagern
die im ausland sicht befinden haben sie
schon gar nicht mehr die die kompetenz
das sicherzustellen dass das so ersten
ganz abgesehen davon dass du da bist du
schon gleich gar nicht genau genug und
damit fragt sekunden da alles ja ohne
oder es einfach mal raum und zeit los
ist wie sie es so propagieren
es ist das schon zum beispiel gar nicht
mehr gegeben
richtig also wo befinden sich die daten
ja wohl erst noch da wo der service in
diesem land passiert ist aber ich kann
sie halt von überall abrufen und ich
kann halt mit diesen daten oder mit
meinen mitteln von jedem ort aus auch
zum beispiel kleine hand und betrieb
frage wo muss ich auf angeklagt werden
in dem land in dem ich mich ein wehle
und das verbrechen begehe oder in dem
land wo der server steht auf dem ich was
vergeht begeht oder in dem land wohnen
irgendwie ich weiß nicht meine
e-mail-adresse registriert ist über die
ich den betrug bedienen also sie sehen
ganz spannende frage macht der raum
zeitlichen verfügbarkeit
da haben sich identitätsdiebstahl
identitäts fälschung zu bekämpfen ja
also diesen thema identität in digitalen
zeiten waren ja hier das recht am wahlen
und abstimmungen teilzunehmen darf nicht
an den zugang zur digitalen medien
gebunden seien
mal wieder die fragen hatten die ist es
mit immatrikulation digitalen attacken
zurück in zukunft wird es keine
möglichkeiten mehr geben glaubt jetzt
analog zu sehen da sagen viele viel zu
unsicher
unser digitales verfahren als wir
einfach die machen da irgendwie ich weiß
ich kann mir alles kennt oder
fingerabdruck scanner ich weiß nicht was
in die wahlkabine müssen sie doch nicht
mal er selbst natürlich voraus dass die
verbreitung der digitalen medien weiter
veranstaltet das wirklich jeder
einstellen
und das scheint mir die größte nur wenig
zeit jeden und jede mit einer
reisegeschwindigkeit ausgestrichen auf
vergessen werden das ist für mich solche
ethischen grundlage auf der die ganzen
dinge die das tier angefahren werden
diese großen freier zugang
der haken heute immer netzneutralität
basieren dagegen anonymen zugang das ist
genau das über das war da eben
gesprochen habe
märz im freien gleichen und anonym
hinzukommen
das wird sehr sehr schwierig sein dass
das uns zu setzen ja ich meine mit vpn
clients also heißt nicht ein virtual
private network ist aber was man damals
haben wieder das virtuelle drin wenn ich
den vpn client davor spannend kann ich
mir aussuchen welches land ich angegeben
mäßig über das ich dann zugreifen
zum beispiel gibt es online stores wo
ich mir deutschland computerspiele nicht
kaufen kann weil sie hier indiziert ist
weil sie zu brutal und viele dann kann
ich zu könnte ich zb wenn ich es wollte
was natürlich nicht ganz legales könnte
ich mich über ein vpn client ein vpn
netzwerk einwählen und simulieren oder
virtual simulieren aus einem anderen
land diese spiele zu kaufen und dann
kann ich es mir kaufen ok deshalb ein
anderes problem wer das private
die em ist eigentlich der
zusammenschluss von wenn sie so wollen
distanzierten netzen zu einem ganzen
also wenn sie die filiale an der einen
stelle haben in der filiale an der
anderen stelle und sie müssen jetzt über
übers internet darüber dann wird halt so
genau zu tun die ente aufgebaut und das
sind dann die die hier die virtuelle in
dem sinne dass es praktisch ein netzwerk
ist aber wird es zwei netzwerke sind
aber werfen als einst genannt da er aber
fortgesetzt werden die importe um die
identität zu verschleiern
weil dann so getan wird als ob man einem
anderen land werden auch lernte elky
bekommt also ganz ganz in der adresse
wird die noch vom provider zugewiesen
die die können sogar angaben sogar
keinen einfluss drauf aber man wählt
sich zu sagen in einem netzwerk bekenne
mich an den letzten teil aus was aber es
simuliert dass man eine anderen land
wäre als und es ist dieses vor diesem
morgen dass sie von einem zum anderen
sondern sich dann ihre spur bringt oder
dass es immer schwierig
der studie zufolge wollte er das
eigentlich dem band ist sich mit einer
elpida und dann kriegst du nicht ein
relativ unverändert
also man kann es müssten zwar zwei
stunden zurück verfolgen und das ist
schon sehr schwierig und teuer ist noch
viel viel mehr steuerehrlichkeit
jedenfalls wird jetzt damit dann gesagt
mit artikel 1 der mit halbsatz 1 artikel
15 dass wir alle mit father and kleinste
mit ochsen oder tornetz da uns die welt
gegeben dürfen oder sollen
das würde das ein bisschen groß folgen
und dabei wird das wenn ich es recht zäh
so ein bisschen skeptisch kreuz und mit
solchen dingen sich das in der welt zu
begeben
also ich kenn ich habe viele kollegen
die machen das gewohnt mit vpn 2 ich
persönlich mag es nicht aber spannende
frage also lief er das ist alles noch
völlig unausgereift wenn man muss gibt
viele angebote ist von solchen ein
kleines aber ich glaube dass auch
einiges geht netzneutralität qualitäten
wettbewerb recht auf vergessen wäre das
mein lieblings artikeln
jeder mensch hat das recht auf digitalen
neu anfangen
dieses recht findet seine grenzen in
berechtigten informationsinteresse der
öffentlichkeit also kurz gesagt wenn ich
einmal im internet spuren mit der weißen
hautkrebs wir nicht mehr aus es gibt ich
habe schon oft darauf hingewiesen dass
gewalt kein berg maschine kann ich kann
ich jede website die irgendwann
existiert hatte wieder herrscht
weil da so zwischenspeicherung punkte
erstellt dann an sie bestimmt
mitbekommen gab es durch diese daten
klar weil politiker vor nicht allzu
langer zeit und die soll das war kein
professionelles basel jugendlicher dem
der hat als alle daten auf solche
falschen poster hochgeladen einfach auf
20 hoch und diese in anderen ländern auf
geschmiedet die werden ja auch intern
gespiegelt die damen wie kriegt man
nicht mehr aussagen und das hängt
wiederum glaube ich mit dieser
reibungslos ich kann mit der raumzeit
dass ein reibungsloser spiegelungen
gehen einfach ohne physikalische
beihilfe leisten ist einfach digitale
objekte die einfach reproduziert werden
können beliebig oft ohne der
physikalischen aufwand zu betreiben und
das begünstigt natürlich die sprünge
niemand verletzt
die weltnummer fixer in westend und
diese spuren haben auch nicht mehr so
zeit index
sie können zwar bestimmt nachfolgen wann
dieses dokument erstellt wurde
aber für die präsentation der besten
abrufen spielt die erzeugung und das
alter der sind
ich sehe dass der seite manchmal schon
an weil das design alt ist und wenn ich
die aufgabe haben oder die datei dann
ist die genau in derselben qualität
setzt mit blasser wie meine innere
stimme dass erlebnisse belassen das
heißt sie haben nur die völlige
repräsentation fonds und das erschwert
diese dimension des vergessens aber auch
das verzeichnis verzeichnet damit dass
sein dass die zeit die wunden heilt und
ich sehe diesen diese möglichkeit im
digitalen nicht grenze blieb riesending
also ich glaube das ist ein wichtiger
punkt da hängt wieder mit dem zeit mit
rauer zeit zusammen so und jetzt geht es
in der diskussion zu diesem artikel
18 nico schreibt am 5 dezember 2016 der
punkt gehört ersatzlos gestrichen
kein mensch hat antrete von den
digitalen neuanfang genauso wenig wie
auf einen analogen neu angefangen jeder
hund mensch muss mit dem leben leben das
er hat dann ist einfach nichts zu ändern
die scheibe ist dass jeder mensch ein
recht und seinen eigenen daten hat
sofern das licht im widerspruch zur
höchst stehende öffentliche interesse
steht
und diesbezüglich ist das existierende
recht schon ganz gut aufgestellt das
recht auf vergessen werden ist ein
totaler unfug man kann niemanden zwingen
etwas zu vergessen und es ist völlig
verkehrt fans torische dann automatisch
ablaufdatum zu fahren und das aktuelle
europa produzierte recht auf vergessen
wer mit lüftet wellküren bzw
es ist richtig dass das recht sich an
neue situation anpassen muss und die
digitalisierung und vernetzung ist eines
solchen ist aber auch richtig dass der
mensch ist eine neue situation anpassen
das ist einfach ein
das vergessen in der digitalisierten
weit weniger schnell und häufig passiert
als es vorher der fall war
das betrifft alle und alles und es hat
vor und nachteile aber es ist nicht zu
nehmen und schreibt der johnny häusler
an nico das recht auf einen aus auf
neuanfang gibt es in der analogen welt
durchaus zu können menschen zb schulden
hinter sich lassen strafen können
entlassen werden und auch verjähren es
gibt die rehabilitation befindet
empfindet das als chance auf annäherung
es ist richtig weil es sagen dass es im
internet alles etwas steht nicht sicher
ob es nun etwas schwieriger geworden
sich glaubensprinzipien ein problem
jetzt schreibt er einen doktor jürgen
müller zu später stunde und sondern am
montag nach und 108 die hier
angesprochene problematik scheint eine
digitale bzw
virtuelle problematisch sein das
internet vergisst nichts
der grund hierfür liegt in der
verzögerten raume zeitung jede
information ist sofort an jedem ort
öffentlich zugänglich und weiter
geknüpft war
sie ist damit dem vergessenen zogen und
kernland reproduzierbar
aus diesem fall scheint mir die
notwendigkeit einen digitalen ethik zu
füllen
von der 1
ewigen bestimmten hinsicht verschieden
zudem muss mit dem sich genau bestimmt
mal da habe ich jetzt eine
schutzbedürftige personen bildung ja
weiter punkte ganze diskussion bildung
jeder ein recht auf bildung die ein
selbstbestimmtes leben begehbaren welt
ermöglicht ab sondern zwei
digitalisierung ist eine elementare
bildungs herausforderungen
sie besitzt einen zentralen stellenwert
mehr leer bleiben öffentliche
bildungseinrichtung schreibt seeräuber
jens das elementar wichtig halte ich die
digitale bildung in den schulen zu wind
kommerzialisierung das heißt bildung so
nicht dort zu führen sondern
jugendlicher bestimmte kommerzielle
produkte ranzinger zu bilden heißt diese
nicht microsoft word lernens und
libreoffice und nicht photoshops und
gibt mit mit safari browser firefox um
die option eines selbstbestimmten lebens
überhaupt bekannt zu machen sollten sie
ferne nicht nur praktisch sind auch
theoretisch vertraut gemacht werden mit
den konzepten von freier software
standpunkt dann steht einer diskussion
ich will kann können die teilnehmer
gerne nachschauen
das hatte ich jetzt hier noch der von
stefan geier bei bildungsmedien der
schule und vorschule zum beispiel
schulbücher zur auf digitalisierung
verzichtet werden
begründung vermeidung digitaler jogi
demenz hier sind digitale demenz
schreibt ein gewisser 400 nur 57 von
unmöglichsten zeiten schreibt analoge
und digitale bildung sollen nicht
gegeneinander ausgespielt werden
entscheidend ist dabei die tugend der
medienkompetenz die frühe schülern
vermittelt werden sollte wie verschaffe
ich mir zugang zur gesicherten
funktionen wie prüfe ich kritisch
quellen wie unterscheidet relevanten von
relevanten informationen thema arbeit
absatz 2 digitalen zeitalter ist
effektiver arbeiten zu gewährleisten
drittens der digitale struktur band ist
noch sozialen grundsätzen zu gestalten
hier muss natürlich klar das kann jetzt
diese artikel arbeite ich leiste muss
überhaupt noch bestimmt werden
dass überhaupt ein digitales ganz klar
gibt es diesen entwicklungen willkommen
darauf auch noch kurz leid zu sprechen
nämlich auf neue paradigmen industrie 40
zu sein zu fordern
das scheint mir ganz wichtig sondern
viele große ethische probleme scheint er
auch mit der arbeitslosigkeit
zusammenzuhängen wieder mithalten durch
die automatisierung zu weit
das ist schluss bestimmung usw so thema
der heutige sitzung eigentlich politik
für die vitalität sondern auch mit
rechten hammer es um politik zu tun
ich möchte auch noch heute die ökonomien
bisschen franken glide war wie
veränderte digitalisiert unseren alltag
und unsere lebenswelt in zukunft welche
allgemeinen gesellschaftlichen
ökonomischen und politischen probleme
gehen damit einher
und dann was ist post humanismus und
lief ins kein realistisches szenario
ich darf immerhin weisen auf dieses
wirklich sehr lesenswerte buch von
philip später mit 150 wichtigsten themen
virtualisierung
das ist natürlich alles auf der ebene
der digitalisierung nicht
das bis 19.10 uhr geht aber dennoch kann
dieses buch als eine grundlage dienen
weil man hier einfach die basisdaten
basisinformationen dieses ganzen
strukturwandels schön übersichtlich
präsentiert bekommen hier sehen sie so
kleinere begriff im hintergrund in grau
cloud da hat mit digitale politik big
data augmented reality und so das sind
die stichworte
was war ein kryptischer begriff unsere
industrie das rückgrat der deutschen
wirtschaft hat seine zukunft in der
industrie 4.0 das einzigste hoch müssen
er hofft auf russland das von jeder wäre
dass darunter nichts vorstellen kann
wird mehrfach rathaus sein was waren
dann bittet industrie 10 20 und 30
vielleicht sind wir heute schon bei 4.01
des kalten wetters zu verdanken haben
wir dieses schlagwort ausnahmsweise
recht des silicon valley sondern einer
forschungsinitiative der deutschen
bundesregierung unter dem überbegriff
industrie 40 wurden auf der hannover
messe 2011 ein konzept vorgestellt das
beschreibt wie unsere industrielle
produktion zukünftig mit moderne wird
hier und kommunikationstechnik verzahnt
werden kann wenn ich gut mit hilfe mit
dem zusatz 4.0 wurde das ziel zum
ausdruck gebracht mit den angestrebten
modernisierungsmaßnahmen eine vierte
industrielle nutzung einzuleiten und
damit über 150 jahre erfolgreich
das trend gibt um fortzuschreiben die
erste industrielle revolution begann der
zweite hälfte des neunzehnten
jahrhunderts und der mechanische
produktionsanlagen die von dampf und
wasserkraft angetrieben
um die jahrhundertwende zum 20 114
industrie 40 er genau die gab's dann
elektrifizierung und industrie finden
beschreibt den zustand unserer
industriellen wirtschaft der ziel
zustand einzelner betriebe mit smart
factory genannt smart fact race sind
alle wichtigen organisationsprinzipien
lebens griffen und wissen ist das
exponentielle fortschritte im bereich
der künstlichen grenzen roboter
verändert den arbeitsmarkt schneller
umfasst als jede bisher in der
automatisierungs will
besonders betroffen sind routine jobs
nicht mehr nur in fabriken und
lagerhallen sind auch von dem
computerbildschirm
damit drohen im gegensatz zu den
automatisierung schäden der
vergangenheit nicht nur den
geringqualifizierten jobverluste auch
beschäftigt in der mittelschicht grad
unter die räder der modernsten warum
sollten unternehmen buchhalter
beschäftigen wenn eine software belege
und rechnungen erfassen kann
wieso sollte anwaltsgehilfen viel geld
in alten gerichtsurteil marschieren will
intelligente computerprogramme in
kürzester zeit zehntausende dokumente
durchsuchen können und welche
arbeitnehmer braucht noch einen
steuerberater wie man die steuern von 0
35 oder ganz einfach per app anreisetag
überlegen sind man wie sieht das alles
war ein haus in der
menschheitsgeschichte sind gemacht
überlegen sie mal warum auch
überhaupt noch beim menschen sehen sie
das genauso drastisch dass hier nicht
nur die kammer die jetzt jobs für
geringqualifizierte betroffen sind
geschichtlich wenn ich so in die
vergangenheit schauen und in bagan von
oder zu 1.0 2.0 und 3.0 crd entstand
stand an der davor vor ähnlichen problem
dass also bestimmte arbeitsschritte
weggefallen sind von maschinen
übernommen worden sind und so weiter und
es hat trotzdem in serie zumindest hier
in deutschland vollbeschäftigung
immer wieder und wieder und ich bin mir
nicht sicher ob man es sagen wir mal die
die zukunft soweit überblicken kann um
nur zu sagen
bis vor allem welcher weg und es kommen
keine neuen hinzu genau
manche karten man kann nicht absehen ob
da nicht in der folge weitere
arbeitsplätze entstehen in dem alte weg
war
hier wird eigentlich immer nur darauf
geschaut dass das wegfällt aber nicht
das neue entwicklung begünstigen kann so
mittag entwicklungen die dann wiederum
menschliche arbeiten die dann natürlich
wieder ersetzt werden kann von
künstlicher intelligenz aber die der
bäder um eure probleme sondern die
wartungsaufgaben einfach mit hofgarten
computersysteme müssen gewartet werden
wenn man können die sich selbst warten
da musste selbst waren das system wieder
gewandert werden wurde die neue kontext
geschehen
mit dieser schwarz malen sich auch der
kleinste gemeinsame nenner der gegenwehr
den beschäftigungs geflossen ist das
zumindest bis 2030 eine mehrheit einem
ins training weiterhin ein arbeitsplatz
musste für uns beruhigend doch wie sieht
die situation in mehreren jahrzehnten
aus die antwort lautet vermutlich mit
jedem jahrzehnt schlechter zumindest
diejenigen die gerne bezahlt arbeiten
nicht die zukunftsforscher richard und
daher süsskind verführen führen ihrem
buch der future auf den professions
guten menschen langfristig ein starker
rückgang erwerbsmöglichkeit
unwahrscheinlich ihre argumentation
sinne abläuft in etwa wie vor
langfristig werde intelligente systeme
fast alle beruflichen tätigkeiten zu
einem erhöhten standard das öl kann als
menschen
sie werden sowohl in unsere kognitiven
auch den emotionalen körperlich
handwerklich und moralischen fähigkeit
überflügeln die skeptiker werden diese
aussage entgegen dass maschinen niemals
möglich decken werden können ebenso
wenig die gefühle empfinden weil ihr
handwerkliches gespürt wege wurde über
das wichtigere verantwortung
reflektieren dieser einwand berechtigt
sein
doch was im beruf wirklich zählt es
nicht gerade preise wie maschinen
arbeiten zum ob sie am ende die meisten
aufgaben besser erledigen als ein mensch
ob sie dazu fähig sind jetzt natürlich
am finger beim einzigen frage stellen
ansetzen bisher eben das argument es
kommt auch das auge auf den output
positiv ist das was am ende rauskommt an
mich auf dem auf dem prozessor des
videos war das nicht so jetzt ja wie
sehen sie das
also könnte stunden also angesehenste
also ich glaube auch dass das nicht ist
weil hier wird zu wenig berücksichtigt
die dynamik dieser ausflug gibt die neue
bedürfnisse aufgeweckt neue bedürfnisse
er von neue arbeiten präsentiert
hergestellt ist genauso wie gehts ja
entwicklung hin zu diesen
sich keiten die grund grundeinkommen das
also aber ich weiß nicht ob arbeit in
unserem heutigen sinne in 10 50 jahren
genau denselben stellenwert hat wie wir
heute wenn man wenn man mal rückblickend
sieht dann war die arbeit früher und
viel wesentlicher teil der der
lebensführung
das hat sich dahingehend entwickelt dass
immer mehr leute mehr freizeit haben
wollten und nicht mehr arbeiten und mehr
geld haben wollten sondern ist euer mal
genau wie die problematik des
hochschulabgänger oder die geilsten
elite er mehr freizeit haben wollte sehr
zum erstaunen der
bronze anstatt mehr geld genau also man
muss ja immer mit einbezieht die
bedürfnisse die trends und darf nicht
einfach davon ausgehen dass arbeit sich
progressiv das arbeitsverhalten linear
also weiter entwickelt dann konnten
weiter punkte zu holen auf höchste was
den ansprachen
unsere arbeitswelt hat sich verändert
und mit viel flexibler
ich darf nun wieder aufnehmen das thema
raubt zeitlichen für eine location wenn
wir immer mehr digitale arbeit ist es
völlig unerheblich von wo wir das machen
und es wird immer problematischer wenn
wir das machen weil er in irgendeiner
global vernetzt sind das heißt ich kann
im takt der amerikaner arbeiten die
bibel zwei verschiedenen haben und
sieben stunden hinterher sind oder im
tag der asiaten dem sieg im voraus sind
ist eigentlich völlig egal solange sich
im tagesrhythmus l
ich kann mich von überall mit einem vpn
client einloggen noch immer mit
einloggen
daran arbeiten
das system dann müssen wir überlegen wie
ich bereich das gab es wichtig werden
man sagt ja immer dass der
dienstleistungssektor größer wirkt sich
das in schule gehen an das produzierende
gewerbe und wie man ab das
dienstleistungsgewerbe zu und zwar
deswegen weil die bedürfnisse immer
individualisierter werden dass man kann
ihm die leute nicht mehr zufrieden
stellen mit einheitsbrei und
dienstleistung sondern muss auf ganz
verschiedenen interessensgruppen achten
das wiederum produziert unglaublich den
arbeitskräfte weil man sich
spezialisieren experte werden muss auf
diesem bereich hat individualisierung
diversifizierung der dienstleistung
daneben auch die arbeit wird flexibler
ich kann von zu hause arbeiten home
office stichwort arbeit wann ich will
ich glaube auch die zeit der
stempelkarte jetzt vorbei sie gibt es
die ja noch teilweise an der universität
bei den und bibliotheksmitarbeiterin
mitarbeiter gibt es bestimmte dinge zu
erfüllen
uns also meine these aber ich finde gut
natürlich gibt es gewisse fristen aber
schauen sie mal jetzt bei der
universitätsbibliothek bisschen das
aufgefallen
vor allem jahr um gefährt man einen
automaten eingebaut der die rückgabe der
bücher stört ich legte es einfach drauf
und der ps3 genauso die ausnahme
ich lege das buch drauftippen ein
passwort an der karte wird gescannt wird
bei uns eine quittung ihrer anleihen usw
das sind riesen arbeitsersparnis und
diese zeit der städte karten dürfte
wirklich vorbei und ich glaube dass
diese dynamische flexibilisierung
wiederum potenzial für neue
arbeitskräfte arbeitsstellen bringt weil
eben auch durch die flexibilisierung und
sehr interessen diversifiziert werden
und weil wir ob sie anders informiert
sind glaubt der dienstleistungssektor
wird immer größer werden auch der
entwicklungs sektor alle der
dienstleistung und der entwicklungs
sektor glaube ich nicht so klar
abgrenzbar sind auch informatiker
programmierens internet-dienstleister
sind auch und die produzieren aber nicht
mehr im klassischen sinne des
produzieren bewährtes und wasser und
punkt sein könnte ist dass man nicht so
gerne pflegen der selbe arbeit arbeitet
das war ja früher ich glaube in japan
ist immer noch so die haben ganz starkes
arbeitslicht reglementiertes
arbeitsleben da ist es die unternehmen
sagte man zumindest wie eine familie ist
ein bisschen ich glaube das sind wir
hier weit entfernt uns gar nicht
bewerten ich glaube hier wechselt man
sehr gerne hier steigt man oben lässt
sich fortbilden
ich glaube auch dass das die zukunft ist
das nicht immer nur im selben bereichen
arbeiten zum flexiblen wird nach neuen
trends ausschau hält
das scheint in die zukunft sind und das
sind alles argumente dafür dass eben uns
die arbeit nicht ausgehen wird weil
diese flexibilität macht trends ausschau
zu halten neue trends setzen und neue
ziele zu formulieren weil das eben
gerade küstengebieten es nicht möglich
ist zu setzen oder bedürfnisse zu
erzeugen
die dienstleistungsgesellschaft lebte
von trends aufzuspüren und bedürfnisse
zu erzeugen also ihr braucht das jetzt
weil das kann er eine maschine nicht
erklären
unterschiedlichkeit vielleicht die diese
produkte herstellt habe ich glaube nicht
dass eine maschine oder künstlern die
ganzen trends setzen können und mehr
gründe dafür nennen können warum ich
dieses produkt jetzt kaufen sollte man
sich hier gibt es glaube ich jede menge
arbeit aber wir müssen fantasievoll sein
müssen flexibel sein das ist die zukunft
und jetzt möchte ich zum schluss noch
hier auf das thema post humanismus
einbringen das ist dieses buch von
arabien havarie prophezeit dass die
menschheit mit dem erreichen nicht
bereiche nicht beglücken wird da der
menschliche geist auf der mannschaften
nur kurzfristig mit zufriedenheit wir
gehen ein stück land ist aber mit dem
verlangen nach mehr
die digitalisierung bietet das
handwerkszeug um neue sich klar
abzeichnende ziele anzustreben nämlich
und sterblichkeit glück und göttlichkeit
wenn sie davon haben
nachdem wir die menschheit über die
animalische des überlebenskampfes hinaus
gehoben
werden wir danach streben menschen in
götter zu verwandeln und aus dem homo
sapiens den videos zu machen
so sieht es gut aus ja was haltet ihr
davon eine geschichte verborgen dass es
jetzt zum ende unseres seminars auf der
heutigen sitzung für diese große
problematik liegt auch immer so ein
bisschen außen vor lassen wollte weil
ich glaube das ist so ein bisschen
futuristen und da kann man nicht richtig
kompetent davon reden weil sie die frage
auf uns das rad zurück gezogen ist die
in wie fern liegt in den möglichkeiten
der digitalisierung sich vor traum
zeitlosigkeit zeitlos die möglichkeit
eines solchen transfer post reminiscence
begründet wie sehen sie das setzt uns
die digitalisierung in den stand über
uns hinaus zu wachsen und neue
dimensionen der existenz zu erschließen
kommen dann steht dann darauf an zu
definieren erstmal was sie darunter neue
existenz verstehen
also ich glaube schon dass sich neues
entwickeln wird und auch an der
digitalisierung ausrichten wird dies in
der vergangenheit auch immer bei
paradigmenwechsel geschehen ist aber wie
die aussehen könnte
also könnte könnte ich mir keinen kein
bild machen und sich weiß ich auch
zurzeit ist es sich mitte des vorigen
jahrhunderts
eine erste mobilität im 21 jahrhundert
hätte sagen können und um das auch nur
annähernd sinnvoll vorausgesehen hätte
um genau so glaube ich und der kommen
noch ein problem dazu dass also die
innovationsgeschwindigkeit immer immer
höher und es damit die systeme die sich
damit ausbilden immer komplexer werden
und es allen noch viel
unwahrscheinlicher ist eine treffende
voraus nicht zurückgreifen
das ist sicher mittelpunkt die
systemische unsicherheit die damit
einhergeht
das sehe ich auch so ich glaube eben als
meint es dir ich in der erste schwarze
bastion ist angelangt weil ich glaube
wir entwickeln neue fähigkeit und frage
neue dimensionen auf die ganze virtuelle
realität
ganz neu ist aber in dieser virtuellen
sphären können wir als freie ist agieren
frei lesen heißt zum beispiel moral
sparte dass wir nicht besser gewesen
werden weil wir eben dann neue
möglichkeit auf das unmoralische in der
digitalen sphäre nutzen
das heißt wir werden neue verbrechen
schaffen
wir werden ganz ohne neue erfindung
neuer gute dinge aber auch neue kormoran
stehende tanzbären entwickeln
insofern glaube ich nicht dass wir die
göttlich werden weil wir als menschen
die über diese zwei seiten haben aber
wir werden neue form des guten und neue
form des urans bestimmt erklärt und
italien
das kölner schildergasse
ja haben sie noch weitere bemerkungen
dazu also ich bin da sehr skeptisch ich
glaube es war so zusammenfasst und
klicken auf das seminar also also die
grundfarbe ist das verhältnis wenn
digitalisierung als technischer seite
und digitalität als von länderseite und
wann man natürlich sagen kann auch
technik ist eine form von kultur
aber ich sage jetzt mal digitalisierung
als wir es um techniken bremen sinne als
nur die technologie und die vitalität
als virtuelle zum wichtigsten als in
serie infos wäre niemand die wird natur
die dritte natur industrie 40 neue
entitäten auftreten und zwar so was
virtuelle gegenstände mit dem plan patin
von nun als virtuelle kommunikation die
raum zeitlich beendet sind also
zusammenfassend gesagt frauen zeit
ändert sich daneben habe er nicht davon
die frage nach rituellen handlungen sich
stellen mit der frage nach der
virtuellen handlung einher geht die
frage nach dem
möglichkeit eines neuen digital ethik
und recht katalogs brauchen wir eine
digitale kritik ich glaube stehen aber
das setzt wiederum voraus dass wir uns
über die grundbegriffe klar werden die
begriffe die handlung die sich hier
verwendet wurden für künstliche
intelligenz sehr kritisch hinterfragen
und dann natürlich die frage nach der
lebenswelt und nicht zuletzt nach der
zukunft das ist eine völlig berechtigte
frage ob es mit neuen technologien zu
tun bekommen wir die fragen ob man nach
der zukunftsentwicklung ich glaube kurz
gesagt dass die menschheit sich nicht
verbessern wird nicht zum homo deus wird
weil wir da viel zu moralischen
aussenden die verlockungen des digitalen
bahnstraße und nicht verschoben werden
aber wir sollten einen blick auf die
ontologie werden und dies und regine
virtuellen realität ist auf eine weise
viel weniger spektakulär als solche
spekulationen die von ray kurzweil zb
der von der singularität spricht damit
will ich sagen dass er die rede und
digital
die vitalität auch nicht und führt somit
künstliches gekämpft aber dass das
interessanter bereich ist aber dass der
den blick verstellt auf das wesentliche
und das wesen die schau mir neue formen
der zwischenmenschlichen interaktions
zahlen neue ethische problem aber auch 9
und um die neue g bestände virtuelle die
bestimmt wie gehe ich damit um virtuelle
realitäten und auch geteilte
wirklichkeiten eines sozial und so ein
stichwort ich glaube dass das die
zukunft ist dass wir bereit sind
vielmehr ist der vergangenheit virtuell
die bestimmen auch werte zuzusprechen
wofür wir früher und paraden immer der
gegen ständig keine physikalischen
realität nicht bereit als zb digitale
dienstleistungen zu bezahlen
dass wir für software immer mehr bereit
sind geld zu bezahlen
software als ein produkt anziehung als
ein gegenschlag
und nicht nur hier ein haus oder eine
tasse ich glaube dass ich dann auch sehr
viel ändern wird
für kleine programme für apps und so
weiter ich glaube wir werden
solche dienst als und kratzern geld zu
zahlen und im werkraum der neueste
stellten existenz gewinnen die nicht
wenn wonach der gerade physikalische
existenz gedacht werden müssen eben auch
unseren von virtuellen existenzen und
bitte ereignisse hatten sie noch
abschließen bemerkungen dazu zu diesem
thema ansonsten wünscht in eine gute und
schöne vorlesungsfreie zeit sei es nicht
das erste ferien weise er vielleicht
noch mal des seminars ich nachschauen
wollen oder vielleicht zu wird in ein
oder angriffen die hausarbeit schreiben
möchte diesem fall nur zeit mit ihr in
verbindung für familie und virtuelle
kommunikation
das gilt auch für die zu hören und
zuhören zuschauen zuschauer
ich werde auch noch den nächsten tagen
alle teilnehmerinnen kann man die
gesammelten zusammenfasste dieses sind
als alle sitze einzelne dokument
verschicken oder sein kleines büchlein
was mir auch zur grundlage
eines gartens digitalität sich hier
schon ankündigen kann welches bank
dieser sehr intensiver diskussion von
ihnen auch im internet im nächsten
jahren wahrscheinlich erscheinen und das
gelernte an der rechten hand machen das
hört sich keine weiteren wünsche ich
ihnen eine schöne zeit und vielleicht
sieht man sich ja den letzten semestern